all right so you might have heard a few
things recently about ninjas and pyjamas
one of eSports is most storied
organizations things like allegations
and evidence of corruption tax evasion
failure to pay players prize money and
contract causes the likes of which would
make your [ __ ] head spin on top of
sifting through all of the known details
and breaking those down for you here
today the score at you sports spoke with
five different players from multiple
iterations of ni P rosters about their
experiences with the organization here's
what we learned
all right so before we actually get into
the breakdown we just need you to know
that this is a really complicated
situation we're working with a variety
of sources and tracking down multiple
different leads so there will be new
videos in the future
just keep it locked back on June 28th
Robin Flair and Johansson a member of
one of the most accomplished csgo
rosters to ever exist tweeted out that
he was fed up about the way he was
treated by the organization and he
wanted to speak up about it which he did
in a July 24th interview with eSports
journalist Richard Lewis I wanted to
tell my story of like 2013 like even
even like n IP in general I think
because I feel like there's so many
unanswered questions from that time see
back in 2012 2013 an IP dominated the
counter-strike landscape one would
assume they want to boatload of prize
money and with all their talk to your
sponsorships I mean they had a chocolate
bar for pete's sake one would assume
that they were at the very least
comfortable oh [ __ ] no they were not
comfortable because around Christmas of
2013 the players were called to an
emergency meeting with two members of Ni
Pease upper management Emile Heaton
Christensen and Robert Himmler and
promptly told that then CEO Nicolas
Fisher had [ __ ] off the Thailand with
all of the prize money from 2012 in 2013
and nobody had heard from him but
according to for flarin this isn't
necessarily the case we don't have any
proof of any of this by the way like
it's just basically they're just telling
us all this and at the same time then
they also then tell us that they already
have an investor stuff this is news that
came out later and I think this is news
that maybe Richard Paz and I think he
mentioned out in the interview with me
too that he said that you know when we
then went back and looked it was since
Nicolas that it took dad's taking the
money to Thailand it was a meal that had
went to the US and spent it all I think
that story it's a story that we haven't
talked about yet because like the focus
is like elsewhere at the moment but you
know I did mention in the interview with
Richard was that I said you know I think
that email got brainwashed and you know
and all that but I never did I say that
I think that he's innocent and oh by the
way Nick didn't even pay taxes on the
prize money that the players never even
received at that time in 2013
Nik was a subsidiary of a company called
Stockholm eSports production AV this
version of n IP is the first of two
iterations of the organization the
players were told not to worry because
despite not being paid any of the prize
money from the previous year Heaton and
n IP management had secured new
investors who theoretically would
provide the funds to pay the taxes on
the prize money that the players never
saw and according to flarin this is what
the players were told there was just one
little caveat oh by the way everything
you've made it hasn't been taxed
everything it just hasn't been taxed for
in Sweden like tax evasion is the reason
why this becomes a very big part of the
decision was that if I get caught for
tax evasion and I had you know and I had
my backside in here from 2013
I had 27,000 Swedish crowns down there
my taxes ended up being 69 thousand five
hundred I could have never paid it and I
was the only one like if anything on my
bank account except for get tried I was
probably the one with the most money so
like we were all in very bad shape and
then this happens
hey he's fled to Thailand your tax
hasn't been paid for all the price
money's gone but we have a new investor
and if Yuri sign with us will make sure
that we pay your taxes if the tax office
catches us if IRS catches us we will pay
your tax money on top of that according
to flarin the players were told that
they need to make up their mind really
fast because otherwise this investor was
just gonna leave now I'm just a kid with
a smile and a dream but even I
understand that it's not the
responsibility of the players to retain
potential investors and the fact that
they were allegedly pressured to make a
quick decision it's just [ __ ] bonkers
but in one specific way the badgering
about resign or won't lose the investors
does make sense
there's obviously stuff that happens in
the background here like ni P is not
just a company it's under Starcom cease
production it's just a side branch brand
so in order to claim an IP you have to
change the company from sarcomas
production and they made the ni p
company now and this I made a tweet I
think two weeks ago when I said you know
the old sponsorships that they claim
these are sourced from back in a day
because like the only thing they did was
you know the NI
innocent pajamas say the same but it was
the underneath the underlying thing that
swapped so now we have a completely new
company so so the conversation was like
because they were doing that they needed
us to basically resize okay so a few
days later the players were called back
for another meeting this time to meet an
MP's principal investor a guy named
Hisham Shaheen all right folks this is
where things get a little weird
to this day Hashem has stated on the
record that he had nothing to do with
the day-to-day management of MIT until
2016 when he officially became the
company's CEO but according to internal
emails for flarin provided to us as well
as an apparent breakdown of a nip annual
general meeting not only was him
involved with calling weekly meetings
and coordinating player contracts with
the organization but for some reason
that we don't yet understand Hashem had
majority voting rights on the board what
this basically means is that at the end
of the day Hashem had final say on
decisions relating to the company and he
had the ability to override anything
that Heaton or the rest of MIT
management wanted to do who here just
has named him rights then it says Amit
so these are the only two basically at
the moment that has a say in NI P and
then on the right here's has a number of
stocks so here's also an EMS mistake in
Sweden there's two separate stocks
there's one stock that's mostly for
money and there's one stock that's for
like power which is why you know you see
number of stocks hit gym only has four K
and a man has 6 K but on the right here
says number of votes and that says 8 k
vs. 6 k so here of a sudden yeah it
looks like a male is majority stake
holder but if you if you actually look
at the end of like the background of the
company that's not true a male here at
this time he [ __ ] up he gave away his
rights to the company at this point
right so now all of a sudden yeah you
have the most stocks but you're not
majority holder anymore and you don't
you don't have the final say and this
document look at top 2014 Oh 410 he
claims he had nothing to do with an IP
until 2016 and now the same csgo roster
that I just completed one of the most
impressive runs in the history of
Counter Strike were presented with
contracts that included clauses that
will shock you now for Flair incentives
what appears to be the final
contract but what's important to note
are the proposed contract clauses that
the players rejected something that
Richard Lewis went over in his original
interview with flarin any violation of
any provisions in the contract means
that they can call forth a contractual
penalty aka a fine of 20,000 euros per
individual violation and the right of ni
p to claim further punitive damages will
remain unaffected
so essentially what they try to slip in
here was if you violated any aspect of
the contract they could find you 20
thousand [ __ ] euros the other clause
which is just as absurd in my opinion it
says that the organisation can set the
status of the player to inactive at any
time of their choosing and if they do
that the player has no right to get any
compensation salary prize money anything
from that day forth and your contract
duration will not be affected by this
decision so in other words they can drop
you at any time you're still under
contract but they don't pay you a penny
and if you're thinking thank god those
clauses didn't make it into the contract
and thank god this is only contained to
the csgo team yeah well not really
this is freezes contract if you're a
league of Legends fan you might know
that he played with NI P from June 2013
to September 2014 I'm gonna read off a
few specific clauses from his contract
that line up with what Richard Lewis
talked about with flarin in his original
interview ni P is entitled to set the
status of the player to inactive at any
time if this case occurs the player has
no right to claim any compensation from
that day forth the contract duration
keeps unaffected in any case and there's
a second clause that's really important
that does seem to match up with what the
flarin and Richard Lewis talked about
any violations of the provisions in this
article shall call forth a contractual
penalty of 5000 euros for each
individual violation the right of Ni P
to claim further damages will remain
unaffected at least there wasn't 20,000
euros I guess on top of that freezes
former teammate Alex ich who provided us
with freezes contract had additional
issues with nip at one point like I was
in the travel visa and you can be only
in there I think it's just like 3 out of
6 months or something like that so
basically your limited amount of time
you can be in the European Union and
then my visa was getting to a point
where I'm not allowed to be in the
country anymore then I came to them
again and I talked to them like is it
fine and they said yeah yeah everything
is in process but then eventually when
we didn't get through to LCS all of that
got into a situation where they're like
yeah you know what
remember all those documents I remember
what exactly they said but basically it
all was like [ __ ] and I was in the
situation where my Z is expired I can
get like initiated banned from going to
Europe anymore and basically when that
happened my wife was with me there too
in the gaming house my son was left with
my son's grandparents
I think her visa was fine I'm not one
hired percent but basically what I did
if I would leave through Sweden there
was a high chance of me getting screwed
over so I checked the country that has
the least chance of checking your visa
the amount of base you were in the
country so I left through Spain and
luckily I wasn't checked and I just got
out and I didn't get the ban from
visiting Europe again this is like one
of the really bad experiences with an IP
probably the biggest one that got me
really depressed I mean the second part
was probably not only me but a lot of
people I will I wasn't receiving the
money from them for a while so they were
owing me like five thousand euro
something like that and basically I went
in social media was that and they paid
me I think in like couple weeks pretty
soon after I went into social media but
before that I was asking them literally
almost every day what about money and
they were sending me to live talk to
different people and then they were
suddenly like disappearing not answering
we also spoke with hand-skin a member of
ni pees dota 2 team in 2015 who
remembers something in his contract
really similar to what flarin and freez
had to deal with first of all like I
always got the impression we were being
taken care of and they really cared for
us but everything seemed a little bit
not so organised like in terms of our
contract negotiations a lot of things
would not be edited when we when we're
doing negotiations there will be slips I
remember we were supposed to sign for a
year and then we when we arrived with
the
contracts and everything instead of two
years I wish I had the contract right in
front of me but I don't what I do
remember was from the Richard Lewis and
fifflaren podcast where they mentioned
the ridiculous what he called the
penalties her defines I remember clearly
that we had the same numbers 20,000
euros as the penalty for you know
whatever penalties they had in their
contract and our salaries were nothing
close to that so I don't think ever
anyone was ever fined for that amount of
money but it was held there so and to
bring it to present day we've spoken
with sources more recently associated
with nip who've expressed their own
frustrations with the organization okay
so where does that leave us well it
leaves us with a ton of questions more
interviews that we're currently doing
and more research that we still need to
comb through but one thing is for
certain this story is not over and we
will have more information for you soon
all right y'all this is where things get
a little weird
all right [ __ ] all right folks all
right people all right ladies and germs
this is where things get a little weird
okay folks I'll do it Germany to do it
one more time that way okay